what is pariston Hill's net ability I've
always assumed it had something to do
with him getting stronger based on how
much he could piss off other people
incredibly appropriate but that would
also be incredibly overpowered to be
fair I suppose everything about
parisston does seem intentionally
designed to annoy people because even
when pariston isn't speaking it's small
stuff like the pompous attitude and
always insisting on sitting on
increasingly fancy chairs with all of
his Delights and sparkles and all of
that is before he actually commits any
transgressions like say I don't know the
various murders he's heavily implied to
have orchestrated but if this were the
case then fighting Jing would be an
absolute pain for powerstone because
unlike almost everyone else Jing doesn't
seem to actually hate pariston if
anything he finds him both tolerable and
intriguing so pariston would really have
to work to break Jing which right now
looks like it's going in the opposite
direction because pariston is the one
developing negative feelings for Jing
gone freaks would of course also be
parrston's natural enemy it's very hard
to break that boy although I suppose we
could always kill kite again to bring up
the up options I think a lot of people
immediately jump onto the idea that
pariston is a manipulator so that could
be a condition associated with that
something like quantifying how annoyed
someone is with him and then once it
reaches a certain threshold the
manipulation takes place I really hope
not though I would prefer that pariston
is just naturally gifted when it comes
to manipulation my theory is that since
angry malice nun is really strong much
stronger than normal then he may have an
ability that can siphon the net of
people who hate him depending on a few
unknown factors so that's the really
strange thing about pariston nen
responds directly to emotion and desire
and parastin doesn't really have strong
feelings towards anyone or anything as
alluded to before Jing freaks is quite
literally the first person in this world
that pariston has felt negative emotions
towards although I should point out that
everything could be buried deep down
because we do have a similar case with
the less than emotive illumi's old dick
but I really like the idea that paristan
on his own is a pretty substandard nen
user and that's due to the lack of drive
but he's still clever very clever so he
might have an ability that turns other
people's emotions and drive to his
advantage and I could very much imagine
that exciting someone like Isaac netra
who specifically hired parston due to
how much of a pain in the ass he was
because all of that annoyance would
result in a better fight consistently
nerfing netro against this frustratingly
weak rat man like imagine netro the
strongest human on the planet imagine
him not being able to lay a hand on
paristan because of how annoyed with him
he is which would only make you more
annoyed with him and thus the ability
that much more effective also this video
is sponsored by dislite the game that
gives you the thing you crave which is
almost certainly a diverse selection of
characters a fresh unique art style and
most importantly a fun game thing to
play although dislike isn't just a game
it's an ongoing series of urban myth
Comics which means that the lore runs
deep set in a stylistic futuristic
Universe colossal portal structures
known as Miracles have descended upon
cities and Unleashed assorted chaos that
can provide certain individuals with the
powers of literal odds and you can jump
into the story wherever you want and the
comics in particular are beautifully
drawn with a distinctive cell animation
style and when it comes to characters
there are infinite possibilities in
dislite as opposed to say the same four
or five different waifu templates that
you tend to find elsewhere and
furthermore every character tells a
unique tale such as in dislike summer
update which recounts the story of
jiaotu's fate of being ensnared in an
eternal cycle of Summer plus you can
participate in various summer events to
earn massive rewards you can directly
support my channel by downloading
dislike from the link in the description
or by scanning the QR code on screen and
using my code will earn you great
rewards to fight the gods and fight for
infinite possibilities so do that thing
but for now it's back to you me I think
it's something like forcing his opponent
into a game in which they have to beat
him with their wit and will this is
because he loves playing games and gets
a thrill from playing just for the fun
so we do have some I would say
underwhelming precedence for an ability
like this which was the ever playful
chi2 who tried to do something similar
with his pocket Dimension ability
trapping the opponent in there and
giving them eight hours to catch him you
know come to think of it we never found
out what would have happened if Morrow
failed to catch chitu in fact chitu
himself didn't even know and it was his
ability that's why he's bad bad cat man
it's a very dangerous thought though
because chichu was able to create an
indestructible Zone which we've also
seen with examples like the Haley
enhanced nenbase no matter how powerful
of a nen user you are you can't damage
the environment due to whatever
conditions were set to create it which
includes nen users like Isaac netra and
this would probably be Parson's most
devastating form of 1v1 completely
removing the idea of physical strength
and forcing opponents to fight under his
conditions and I think that pariston
would be especially annoying in this
sort of circumstance because he'd have a
whole ton of restrictions and
limitations because his whole thing is
about both not wanting to win or lose
the game so he'd have all sorts of
unpredictable conditions many of which
may even give the advantage to his
opponent but also we don't need to go so
far as to create an end Dimension this
game could exist in an augmented reality
which is what most if not all none
abilities actually do I bet it's an
ability where he picks a playmate and
then forces them into a game he was
playing with netro before and now is
going to start the game with Jing after
Cheeto failed to prove herself a worthy
opponent so we have a similar game line
of thinking but the idea here is that
the ability only works on one Playmate
at a time which is actually quite common
a lot of net abilities in the series
have restricted targeting like say
Knuckles APR which can only be active on
one target at a time and most
manipulators have limitations of one to
two Targets with the absolutely stupid
exception of illumi who was a
manipulation God but something else I'd
propose is that the longer the game
lasts the more benefits the ability
provides to pariston because again he
isn't trying to win in fact I think Jinx
says it best he doesn't intend to win he
isn't trying to lose either that's why
he's hard to beat whether it's part of
an ability or just his social
preferences pariston wants the game to
last as long as possible which is also
why he doesn't bother with boring
opponents like Cheeto the game ends too
quickly clean he doesn't get anything
out of them that might have been his
plan with the election actually
initially parston tried to skip the
election entirely by nominating himself
and then claiming the election was
unnecessary although this was probably
just to annoy people even more however
it may also have been because you know
he saw the candidates and was like yeah
no one's really worthy of playing with
me I mean even Jing at that point might
have been a bit of a meh proposition
because you need to remember up until
this stage pariston's Playmate was
netterer and how do you top that all of
the zodiacs are a downgrade from that
and those two would have played an
insanely long game as well pariston was
vice chairman for three whole years and
during that time his Focus was solely on
the hunter Association and nettera so to
lose that three-year rival and be stuck
with the zodiacs yeah that would
definitely feel a bit underwhelming it
sickeningly twistedly sweet but pariston
legitimately misses nettera for all of
the wrong reasons mind you but that is
another rare Showcase of Paris and
emotion however minimal it may be he
either has the most complicated
inability or the simplest one but I'm
pretty sure it's a twisted ability
nonetheless I could see this happening
for a variety of reasons but one of
which is simply personality based Jing
equated Paris to netro went himself as
something of a menage our charactois
claiming that the three of them all had
shockingly similar personalities with
the key difference between Jing and the
other two being patience Jing has none
of that whilst pariston and netro seem
to have a global Monopoly on patience
but I point that out because netro's
ability as powerful as it is is really
simple the idea is just I'm gonna summon
a punch statue and it's going to punch
you now which was achieved through how
many years of just punching simplistic
punching but also the Simplicity is such
that in effect it has infinite
combinations which can be used due to
over the 99 hands although I think a
more interesting comparison might be
hisoka he and Paris can definitely share
certain traits with the key difference
being that hisoka is always driven to
win to harvest the fruits of his erotic
battle tree whereas paristan doesn't
care whether he wins or loses in fact he
doesn't want either he just wants the
game a long infinite game but it's very
easy to see pariston with an ability
like say bungee gum simple but versatile
and most importantly very very annoying
even to a top tier nen user bungee gum
is just plain frustrating because hisoka
uses it in such Sly clever ways and
hisoka might also be a pretty bad
matchup against pariston because I
really can't see hisoka actually getting
annoyed come to think of it I don't
think we've ever seen hisoka get angry
even when he was about to die he was
kind of on the verge of coming but
hisoka and parastin would be an
interesting doer and fun fact parastin
in the 2011 anime is voiced by Hiroki
Takahashi who just so happened to voice
hisoka in the 1999 anime so they both do
a fantastic rendition of mischievous
demon boy but I also like Paris
nenability being simple because it would
continuously make his opponents paranoid
about other applications like imagine if
you're fighting pariston he pulls out
something simple and in your head you're
just like it cannot be this simple he is
too complicated for this and that just
keeps going through your head over and
over until the simple ability beats you
although speaking of the mind I think
it's got to be a mind-based ability
potentially similar to comogies in
relation to gungi but in order to
predict what other people are going to
do or something of the sort basically
enhancing the mind kind of yeah sort of
so komiki's ability doesn't give her the
power to predict others you know it's
not like seradnik's parallel future
comedy's heart to his geared towards
continuously developing hogungi so it's
more like it allows her to innovate
rather than anticipate although the
latter would certainly come as a result
of the former what I would like is for
pariston to have an ability that more or
less gamifiers real life like say his
ability is called dialogue wheel and
when speaking to people he receives
three to four options leading to the
most interesting outcomes to choose from
and that might also explain why losing
is just as if not more fun than winning
because sometimes he might choose an
option for the sheer chaos of it it
sounds a little bit ridiculous but
honestly it is not Beyond tagashi to
gamify Hunter Hunter again he is a
notorious RPG fanatic I mean Greed
Island that whole Arc only exists
because of his game aiming Obsession and
even now in the succession War morena's
ability is to create one big murder game
so to give the biggest fan of games in
the series a game-related ability would
be quite fitting in my opinion but also
maybe it could be something like in
every conversation pariston has he's
able to see two lies and one truth about
his enemy and it's up to Paris to put
that information together to form a
conclusion his known ability is called
sinking ship where like rats running off
a sinking ship he can clearly see the
best path to survival I actually quite
like this I like this a lot the idea
that his Aura quantity is quite low and
his physical prowess is nothing special
as well but he has this uncanny ability
to always select the path avoiding the
thing that could actively threaten him
for example he's sparring against netro
and despite the former chairman well I
guess they're both technically former
chairman now but despite netro's speed
pariston just knows exactly where to be
to avoid the hits that he can't even see
coming like say he always trips over at
a convenient time to avoid netro's
attacks or something frustratingly
stupid like that he's a assistance
problem like an insect infestation no
matter how much effort you put in you
just cannot get rid of Paris I think he
is in the top three of whatever we saw
but his restriction is he can only be
this strong when no one expects it
alright so sort of like The Invisible
Boy and Mystery Men Who can only turn
invisible when no one was watching
thinking about it though Paris didn't
despite his position as a zodiac is
constantly underestimated even by Jing
although to be fair since we don't know
the true extent of his abilities he
could just be estimated or even
overestimated whatever it is I think we
can all agree that pariston's Essence is
best summed up by the word trap because
he appears all friendly while dressed
and sparkly and all but all of that is
for the purpose of making you drop your
guard and luring you into the Trap I'm
going to guess the more you find out
about the ability the more powerful it
is against you that seems like a really
trolley trap Harrison would lay I can
imagine that pariston deliberately
creates an exceptionally painful ability
with like 10 restrictions and maybe a
bunch of sub restrictions as well
basically creating an end puzzle for the
opponent to solve with each correct
solution seemingly bringing the opponent
closer to Victory but in reality it's
drawing them further and further into
the Trap until discovering that the
final condition is having discovered all
of the conditions and by that point it's
too late it would be such an amazing
nentral and it would completely flip nen
Combat on its head because with Nan
information is everything so to
effectively fight paristan you would
need to go completely against your
instincts you would have to actively try
not to analyze anything that's happening
it's so counter-intuitive but I could
see Togashi writing a very fascinating
fight like that I think if as you
considered he is a transmuter it would
be something ridiculously simple like
transmuting his Aura into those little
sparkles that we're used to seeing
around him at all times that's Fair
perhaps we're all severely overthinking
this comparison takes example of all of
that mental strain to do something
really simple like just whack you with a
bat and also maybe it has something to
do with his series of glamorous chairs
or phenomenal suits although the hunter
hunter mubarger card game has this image
of Paris in more casual attire and look
I'm gonna be honest I don't know how to
feel about it sort of like a dad sitting
on his comfy dad chair but outside for
uh some reason but you let me know in
the comments what do you think
parastin's net ability is